si on laisse faire emmanuel macron on va
vers des ruptures en la matière je pense
des ruptures grave avec ce qui fonde est
malgré tout un tas de choses qui avait
été attaqué ce qu'on appelle le modèle
social français qui était un modèle qui
visait quand même un certain
développement dont l'égalité de la
société il est là il a dit c'est ce côté
arthur sociale il faut ce qu'il faut
pouvoir se la payer
parlant de la collectivité de la société
dans son ensemble vous avez noté cette
phrase oui mais c'est la célèbre par
exemple c'est la rupture avec avec avec
le modèle actuel parce que le modèle
actuel c'est un modèle de solidarité
entre ceux qui à un moment donné sont
dans la difficulté
soit parce qu'ils sont dans la maladie
soit parce qu'ils perdent leur emploi ou
est un modèle de solidarité inter
générationnelle ceux qui sont actifs
payent par leurs cotisations sociales
les retraites des plus anciens c'est ce
modèle qui fait justement la solidarité
de la société qu'on essaye de mettre en
pause et je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise chose